the word magic means a lot of different
things to a lot of different people it
can be exciting mysterious helpful and
even evil but the word itself is neither
good nor bad it merely describes a host
of different practices and beliefs that
are listed these emotional reactions it
really comes down to what you think
magic is now the term blood magic
conjures negative imagery for most
people and that is understandable
considering blood itself is the one that
we associate with things such as war
death and physical injury blood magic in
turn is then also confused with human
sacrifice and blood sacrifice but that
isn't necessarily what it always refers
to the entire notion of sacrifice in
humans and animals on altars with
pentagrams and all that demonic stuff
doesn't entirely represent the way it's
practiced today in its simplest terms
blood magic or blood sorcery simply
involves a drop or two of blood during a
spell or a ritual and it's usually the
blood of the individual performing that
spell or ritual so nobody else is
actually harmed in the process many
forms of magic involve a tool or an
object that harnesses or amplifies that
type of magic and in this case that
object is blood with a lot of magical
spells and rituals you are essentially
asking for something which is why it's
so common to give something in return
this can be voluntary and other times it
may not be I'm sure we've all seen a
movie or a TV show where someone
performs an act or a spell and they
either end up fainting or with some kind
of nosebleed they get what they want in
terms of that spell or action but
something is taken in return be it blood
which can be interpreted as life or
something else entirely different hence
the very common idea that magic has a
cost or all magic comes with a price
now in terms of what one is able to do
with blood magic it doesn't seem like
there are many limitations which in
itself could be another reason why it
has such a bad reputation
it may not be inherently bad but one can
still use it to do terrible things it
comes down to the moral compass of those
using blood magic the blood is merely a
conduit what you choose to do with it is
entirely up to you now with this whole
series exploring magic once we've gone
over the overall premise we then look at
how it appears in works of fiction so to
begin we can take a look at Game of
Thrones or A Song of Ice and Fire
depending on which you prefer in the
work of george RR martin blood sorcery
is considered the most powerful form of
magic but it's also a dark heart
forbidden to many in season one when
Drogo lay there dying
Daenerys summons Miri Mazda a blood made
from the land of Lazzarini she
eventually tells Daenerys that she can
save Drogo but she'll need to take a
life in exchange which happens to be his
horse we then need to learn that Meera
master had no intention in using her
powers to save Drogo she instead wanted
revenge for what happened to her people
and for this she is burnt alive in
season 3 when Stannis Baratheon learns
that Gendry is the bastard son of Robert
Baratheon they use leeches to collect
his blood believing that it can be used
in powerful rituals which it later is
later on in the first episode of season
5 we have a flashback to young Cersei
Lannister visiting a witch named Maggie
and asking for her future to be red
Cersei then counts her thumb in order to
draw some blood and in quite a weird
scene the witch then proceeds to suck on
Circe's thumb but she does tell Cersei
that she will become a queen and have
three children who will all die before
her and eventually she will be replaced
by a younger more beautiful Queen
there are several characters in Martin's
work that use blood magic and what they
use it for varies but for the most part
he is consistent with the idea that
blood magic comes with a cost often
needing a sacrifice in exchange for a
great amount of power
we also see blood magic in the TV show
loss go what if I'm being completely
honest is terrible but there is a
character called trick who is described
as a blood sage anything trick writes in
his own blood then comes true but there
is always some kind of catch or
consequence he only really uses this
power to try and maintain peace and as a
last resort as you may expect the way
blood magic appears in fiction is
different to how it's seen by those who
practice it today and I think the
reasons for that are quite obvious in
terms of authors wanting it to appear
more dark and taboo in order to excite
and interest readers but let me know
what you think about blood magic in the
comments below you can also throw in any
blood mages or books that you feel
deserve a mention if you have enjoyed
this video then please consider leaving
a thumbs up as it really does help me
and the channel as always I've been your
host mythology and fiction explained
you